politics in prose bookstore in
Washington DC book TV recently recorded
the group's discussion of China Inc how
the rise of the next superpower
challenges America and the world before
we show you the discussion here's a
portion of an interview with the book's
author Ted Fishman from the producer of
Book Fair in Chicago we asked mr.
fisherman how he got the idea for the
book well I was trying to shift focus of
Americans from everything else in the
world except China and recognize what is
going to be the biggest economic force
in our futures and for me that was just
an experiment in walking around my house
seeing everything was coming from China
everything in my drawers and my kids
rooms and saying hey there's a global
force coming here it's going to affect
all of us as citizens workers parents as
consumers and the book really tries to
get deep inside that dynamic and show
how China will be something essential
for all of us to think deeply about in
the coming years how soon do you think
this is all going to happen it's here
now I mean you can walk around Walmart
where 7 out of 10 of everything that
walmart sells has a very significant
China component in it and look at the
statistics on job loss in the United
States that's all being driven by
dynamic in China either the Chinese are
taking jobs directly or they're forcing
American companies to find solutions to
their own labor problem and often that's
machines which is putting Chinese out of
work and of course you know you can't
open up the paper these days without
seeing some big question about China
whether it's financial economic
geopolitical when I started the book in
2003 China's really the back pages of
the business section now it's routinely
on the front page of every paper one or
two stories every day just try and spend
a day shopping without buying something
in China it's virtually impossible you
know I'm in the book business recently
because I wrote China Inc and bookstores
are among the only places in which most
of the things are still made in the
United States but you you talked about
buyers going to going to places where
they can't buy things from China you
know the most important buyers in the
United States are not retail buyers the
most important buyers in the United
States
are the ones who contract for the
Chinese goods that come in you know we
have a nearly a hundred and seventy
billion dollar trade deficit with China
this year and you know some of the
estimates are really high you know they
might go over 170 all the way to two
hundred and forty billion dollars and
all of those Goods come in because an
American company is bringing them in and
those numbers are a real good measure of
how much money is being made on the
China trade by American companies and
what it highlights is the two different
hats that America wears where Chinese
Chinese goods are purchased we wear them
as corporate buyers and consumers in
which we want the cheapest things but of
course we wear this important hat which
is that of worker and you know as our
standard of living gets goes down
because some industries migrate to China
it goes up on the consumer side and we
have to decide as a country you know
where we're going to emphasize the
benefits of our economy are we going to
try as hard as we can to keep the
standard of living high on the working
side or are we going to continue to push
so that we benefit on the consumer side
gary Hofbauer at the universe at the
Institute for International Economics to
this great calculation for me which was
in 2003 China saved the average American
consumer at every American on average
550 dollars not just because Chinese
goods are cheaper but because it makes
goods from all over the world have to
compete with low-cost Chinese goods and
you know that's about four times the
Bush tax cut for a family of four and
you know we didn't have to deficit spend
to get it on the other hand you know if
Americans are making less money because
they're losing their jobs then then we
need those savings China is now the
world's second largest consumer of
petroleum just Pat's surpassed Japan and
it will need the sea lanes open to it in
exactly the same way that the United
States tries to guarantee its energy
supplies so this is a potential force I
mean this is a potential issue for
conflict between our countries in the
future and something we have to be
really really watchful for on the
positive side you know the kinds of
energy shortage
which rule china will face and we'll
export we'll export it shortages because
it will be a major consumer putting
demand demand on energy prices worldwide
is that it could really push us to
alternate energy supplies and
alternative energy technology China is
very interested in hybrid automobile and
in other alternate technologies for the
automobile because it will be the
world's largest consumer of automobiles
in within a generation or a generation
and a half that's not a bargain for
anybody in the world and we really need
alternatives in order to solve that not
just from the supply side but because
the pollution would be so horrendous so
who would like to begin the discussion
on China Inc and how you felt about the
book and I was telling everybody before
I came I'm glad I don't live in China
and they all looked at me with high it's
a great place to visit so Meredith how
about you have it if you start um well
couple things look I thought it was
quite interesting it's not quite as
linear as I like saw like all books to
kind of be an outline form but I'm a
very rigid person um but the thing I've
always interesting is that there's been
a lot of theories that this country or
that country is going to overtake the
u.s. since we have destroyed the
standard of living forever so go back 15
years and look at kind of the view on
Japan it was a very similar thing Japan
was going to they had they were leaping
ahead the US has been destroyed the u.s.
standard of living I don't know that
much about the rights that were done at
the time in Japan but it seems like kind
of a parallel scare tactic which is kind
of what I responded to in the book I
thought if you look at some of the
issues in China I mean they've got a
huge financial bubble brewing our
banking system is overheating there's a
lot of issues out there that were not
touched on in the book the major
difference which your pan there's a
population of China we may have they
just bubbling out of the ground and they
can do anything with what amazed me is
that many of these
modern factories didn't have robots for
electronics pages have lots of people
it's true well in some ways though it
isn't the other way it's also to the arm
the population is an advantage and a
terrible disadvantage I mean you read
about strikes you know mild started out
as a communist side he was going to
organize labor workers into a communist
party but in fact it was done by peasant
rebellion in the periphery of China and
it's those 800 million people I don't
know if it's in this book but either
here or elsewhere I read someone saying
that what's actually happening is the
rural people are becoming poorer because
the enormous growth in the cities is
pushing up prices of commodities whereas
their income is dropping that is they're
worse off I mean I kind of agree that
movement in history is not linear it
doesn't you can't just take a trend and
extrapolate it forever it doesn't work
that way and I think the Chinese
leadership is sitting on a very dicey
situation yeah I mean I'm not predicting
that it's going to go terribly wrong but
boy it's certainly good but you know I
think that one of the points he made in
the book well he said what I got out of
the book was that we really haven't done
anything to go against the Chinese we
seem that everybody seems to be sitting
back and saying you know they're they're
gonna crumble they're gonna go so was it
term all the stuff like that and
meanwhile you know he talks about he
pretty much slams our education system
and how little we've done to where
Grassley talks about the 1830s workforce
which is supposed to be your most
creative workforce is kind of you know
we tend to to indulge ourselves in silly
little things well the population over
there poor as they are there's they're
pushing hard to learn English that
they're doing things that that we don't
seem to have parity over here I mean he
basically paints a picture that we're
pretty complacent of and I think just
sitting around waiting for them to fall
oh they're so
it is probably not a good tactic for our
country as a whole
that's even more activist and I think we
are we're not waiting for them to school
on their sword we don't really think
about them yeah actually we're handing
those swords well I think I think one of
the advantages that China has in a sense
in their growth is that they start from
next to nothing unlike Japan they start
with a standard of living which was
virtually nothing in the farmlands and
all that and so even small improvements
to the Chinese people seem to be very
large so I think they've got a long way
to go and I do think that the the
countryside seems to be fueling the
migration to the cities and there's a
sort of a reciprocity where the young
people who go to the cities and get jobs
in manufacturing send whatever little
money they can back to the farm villages
so what you've got is a sort of a
selection process going on where the
best and the brightest are called out of
the villages and they go off to the
cities to participate in this
I guess industrialization so I think
they've got a long way to go before they
fall on their sword unless it comes
unless it comes as a result of the
demand for energy which is something
that they really don't have a good
analogue the amount of energy they need
to fuel the expansion that they're
undertaking is enormous and so I mean it
may be something like that
the scarcity of resources which
eventually slow down the changes but
since they start from nothing beeping
people the people are willing to work
for nothing on a willing basis I mean
this is not slave labour these people
are happy to have these jobs so they're
doing it voluntarily so I think China I
think China is a country to watch in
terms of an economic miracle so speak I
wouldn't want to live there either I
mean that's the second I mean
to go one step further but I do think
that is an economic miracle in the
process of happening what we this
holding on their sword I'm not sure what
that was not my expression but a number
of people have repeated it is this the
idea that there's going to be a complete
collapse in China I mean I don't get my
ups and downs like every normal economy
has but the idea that it's you know in
many ways the current economic growth in
poorer countries in the world is
enormously beneficial to the whole world
and I don't think anybody would really
want there to be a complete collapse
maíam I thought was simply that it's
going to be an economy that will have
subs and downs is every other economy
does it may hit a plateau yeah I don't
think that's what he's implying here and
I would agree with you I would think
that China would develop in many ways
that other developing countries have but
he seems to be suggesting that they're
going to be smarter than the rest of us
and they're going to do everything
better yeah there's something inexorable
about the march forward as he describes
it and I'm wondering about the time bomb
of AIDS there and wondering if the
effect will in any way parallel what's
happening happening in Africa and taking
out exactly that segment of the
population that's supposed to be the
most productive and the most creative
the whole bird flu business that they
don't report to the World Health
Organization they don't seem to manage
it internally in the very size of the
place I didn't get an impression from
this book that they actually have a
handle on what's happening all over the
country and the way we sort of assume
that they do or and the way it's painted
here that they really do know I see some
I don't know that I'd call it falling on
a sword I see time bombs going off or
the possibility of time bombs going off
and they've only now gotten a hold of
aids for example never done at least
according to him they're 10 million
cases which may be a drop a large number
to us and a small number to them but as
we know it doesn't take a lot it's the
same with India they're only just now at
the 11th hour waking up to the AIDS
crisis where is this been festering for
quite
for years now in India so I I'm just not
sure I agree with you I've questioned
the inexorability of it I've started
responding to that and thinking well if
it were so an expert bull why has China
ever fallen off the forefront
if population and smarts and hard work
were the things that were going to get
them always ahead we heard about this as
he said about Japan and Germany in the
past so and they haven't you know they
haven't kept up their 10% of your growth
so as Valerie was speaking I thought to
myself this isn't something unique I
don't know how many of you are first I
said it second generation Americans I am
my parents were born in Europe and the
best and the brightest left they work
for nothing my father said well if he
doesn't have it he ate another role in a
role for two cents he'd walk up to the
fifth floor and they sent money back so
on a European scale all right I scan
that we can talk about it's not that
different
I think the thing one of the things that
struck me about the book was just the
largeness of numbers and how it relates
to China the industry the interesting
fact that I remember well is the
population estimate itself where the
Chinese government estimates about 1.3
billion people using nothing I mean not
trying to trick anybody they seem to be
estimating that whereas our own
intelligence community seems to say 1.5
billion based on grain sales and all
that doesn't sound like a big difference
except the difference in effect is us
right you know point two billion in in
counting is roughly the size of America
the margin of error is just the sheer
magnitude of the country and I mean it's
just mind-blowing and the potential that
exists in those corner in those numbers
of four smart people and the Chinese do
seem to be trying to develop the smart
people through their educational system
and even now a lot of people are getting
left behind but that's you know just
because of the size of the numbers
the ones that are moving on is a
substantial block of people the
difference may be Taiwan with you count
them in or not well maybe what I want
another interesting is interesting
comment that he make the point he makes
in here about how many people from
Taiwan are going over to partake in the
mainland business right yeah I mean that
they're they're not they're not
pretending there's a big separation
there's a lot of people in Taiwan going
to take advantage of the growth which
was a surprise to me what I thought was
interesting and kind of scary in a way
was you know that none of this really
happened as if like the country
mobilized itself and in some organized
fashion things just kind of popped up
and it's almost like a free market
effect whereas you know entrepreneurs
that are taking their own actions and
and even the villages are taking their
own actions and it's grown from that
which typically you know those things
tend to sustain itself those that kind
of growth tends to sustain itself a lot
more than just something that's propped
up and so you know you know I think
there I think you said is doing the
Asian financial crisis they were not
completely immune but they weren't as I
mean their gdp was still growing during
that process and so they might be a
little more a lot more stable than you
know than anyone would give them credit
for it and we think yeah
well what about the analogy to to India
I mean isn't India doing exactly the
plate you know you could let you grow
prop I write the same book about
contemporary events in India there's
they're about 10 years I think behind
China because they didn't abandon the
socialist ideas and start encouraging
stuff until about 10 years later but
India tube is moving very much in the
same direction and it seems to me many
of the things he says about you know
they already have the advantage they
have enormous number of people who speak
English and the outsourcing things are
therefore going to India for example
he's in for you you know when you ask
when you get a phone call or something
to accompany you talking to somebody
from India I mean I've had everybody
said that experience I think already
like for example the cost of
manufacturing is so much higher in India
than it is in China I mean everyone
looks just like you you know I think
janna overall isn't going to do you know
isn't going to take over the world all
at once but you take a look at one
segment and it's proven empirically that
they can pretty much wipe out
manufacturing the way you know
agriculture in the US has wiped out a
lot of developing economies because they
just basically take the whole at the
entire market away from it and you know
stuff like manufacturing takes a bit of
time to to get yourself geared up to get
past the barrier you know the entry
barriers and so that's the that's a
glooming danger ahead I think the rest
of the world
well that manufacturing is actually one
thing I thought he had hyped too much
we've heard all this before that we're
losing all our manufacturing capacity um
from the Washington Post and I think the
Economist what I keep on reading is that
you know all this globalization usually
is only attributable to like one or two
percent of the jobs that are lost in the
United States so most of the jobs that
are lost really are for internal reasons
or for some other reason not
globalization not over you know
outsourcing to all these countries so
you know he says that that's all been
understated in reports but I don't know
I think he's being a bit alarmist
compared to what else I've read I
thought that was interesting though
because when the concept of the race to
the bottom so you probably need a
marginal number of jobs that are
outsourced or on suppliers or no sure
and I like you I very don't like it but
I'm
I respect his argument saying okay well
then everyone else has to compete so if
you do have a check of let's say I don't
know a couple million jobs your
suppliers offshore that reduces calls to
certain demanding and everyone have to
compete elsewhere then you can rise in
productivity greater investment capital
so focus on fewer jobs we've heard that
before though I am ninety percent of the
goods and services are internal in this
country I mean I've read that from
Krugman and few other people so um you
know we keep on here and again for you
know last fifty years that you know
everything is going to be manufactured
somewhere else but you know it doesn't
seem to happen or at least having very
very slowly what address immediately
American companies the only one comes in
live a normal and going and have to
cooperate or else they will not have the
market so Boeing knows that they're
creating competition Boeing knows that
they are building factories and
transferring the knowledge to run these
factories which will ultimately compete
with Boeing but they have no alternative
if they want to stay competitive in
China and I don't think I've ever heard
this and with respect to India was it
one thing I thought about too was did
anybody write a similar book in 1900
about the United States you can imagine
some new originated in the u.s. by 1900
the United States was already the
largest economy in the world and I
wonder if any European didn't write a
diss exactly a similar book you know
it's the population is bigger they got a
lot of migrants immigrants coming in ten
million immigrants you know between 1900
and 1910 I know what it is 10 or 20
million
we're pouring into the United States you
could have written exactly the similar
book and the same thing about the
culture of knowledge the Europeans were
investing a high percentage of
investment came from England did you
take that if you take that argument to
its limit if in fact United States did
prove to be the world's economic power
oh no wishing and woody and in terms of
being nationalistic you could to say
that that's terrible but in terms of the
way the world developed wasn't that a
good thing yeah and what is so clear
that China is going to be you know that
it seems to be the rise of poor
countries becoming rich it's not a bad
thing is it well no no no not by itself
what concerns me though about it when in
addition to not seeing the time bombs
like I thought I saw he knows a lot more
than I do but having said that not not
acknowledging them I was struck by the
ruthlessness and the lack of interest in
the effect on individuals that China
seems as part of it seems to have as
part of its operating system so that if
the rise of China means that it
dominates the way the United States has
dominated and that's the philosophy that
then gets either exported or imposed I
do have a problem with that I think that
for all of the pushback especially that
we're seeing now I don't know that the
United States but the United States
imposed something bad on the places
where its economic power got exercised
in terms of individuals maybe did that
maybe pollyannaish but the ruthlessness
with which China goes about doing what
it does just placing peoples and not
caring what happens in the rural section
as long as the urban area of the economy
develops I thought was breathtaking and
not something I would like to see spread
a whole lot further concern a little
different perspective I'm concerned
about judicial issues and human rights
it was one section on I can't find it
about the ripoff of products the copycat
or the broad Yulin reduction of us name
brands but not paying attention to any
US copyright you know rules I'm not sure
every country in the world has to but
I'm sure others do when they manufacture
things with name-brand
but somebody mentioned I think you the
people are calm or under control or I
forget the word but from my knowledge of
the half-a-dozen people I've met and
tried to email with they're terrified of
doing emails because they know they
think their emails are monitored and of
course I'm a political person so that's
what I would talk about and I did in
exchange with someone about trying to
get citizenship for a daughter-in-law
but
the other thing is the union issue or
the suppression suppression of people
issue and I think that's going to
explode I I think they're under such
constraints right now politically that
there's going to be another tiannamen
square or something where after people
are not are figure out how they can
express themselves they aren't able to
and they're they're under tight control
and they have to take whatever wage is
offered to them and they don't have
health benefits that I saw many beggars
in the street in this was a year ago I
guess at bus stop stations and train
stations and people with amputations and
such and I asked our guide who are these
people why are they here well they were
industrial accidents they thought they
lost arms and legs and on it homemade
crutches and there is no workers
compensation and there is no OSHA or you
know anything that sets Labor Standards
so those that's the collateral damage if
you will from the low wages and the
prices the competition that they're
trying to be for the US for other
countries just sorry just taking what
you said I think the essential question
is will China develop the way we want it
to will all the the riches the the
growing middle class you know finally
force the government to bring them you
know more human rights better judicial
system you have better health care or
are they going to keep their kind of
bargain that they don't talk about
politics and government can do what it
wants and and I think question is you
know how long will that continue and or
will it change ever what do you think I
tend to be optimistic myself I not thing
and what does that mean
in that's in that I think that there
will be a similar middle-class you I
don't know whether it'll be you know
peaceful process but I think the middle
class will eventually demand the same
kind of things that our middle class is
demand but is the good to the middle
class is pretty much turned its back on
on the lower it's a lower class of
suffering enough all the people that the
book even said that all the other
intellectual the students whatever that
will be high in the whole Tiananmen
Square event back in 89 pretty much off
doing well on their own in living the
urban life and no one is really for the
time being I don't think anyone has
really started to mobilize the peasant
class which is really the one that the
mass of the number and the ones that
that is going to ultimately have any
grievances against what's being done I
think the middle class is is set I mean
it's almost like that they're complacent
to you know doing what they're doing to
to keep things rolling factory worker
where did this middle class come from by
the way that's one of the things he did
not dress in the book so he talks a lot
about 70 million out-of-work peasants
pulling for 40 cents an hour and he sort
of vaguely referenced the middle class
and that you know there are people
buying V CDs or what-have-you but where
did the what's great in the middle class
and
but when he talks about you're gonna
leave these shopkeepers who just arrived
in the city set up a shop expanded so
that eventually had a factory those
making little doodads oh matey that's
exactly what's happened apparently but a
lot of people have just seized small
opportunities lots of little into
Burleigh I'm good so it does the middle
class it's an entrepreneurial most
becoming the planets you've also got
because the Communist Party for anything
is a lot of the relatives of Communist
Party leaders have enormous
opportunities just like in Russia you
know they set up these they're closing
down a lot of the government factories
and replacing them with privately owned
things and probably the offspring of
Communist Party leaders are first in
line to get the goodies but I was in
conveying in western China and you Dan
which is way out in the middle of
nowhere it could bring is well in the
daytime you know you're driving through
a village and you see the villagers
going in on bicycles and arcs cars to
sell her things at the market this is
about 10 years ago and you get into Quin
Ming and we were staying in this
tremendous hotel which I couldn't even
afford the United States and you walk
through Quin Ming and you had these
Gucci all the brand names from Europe
they were little shop with shopkeeper
selling these fantastically maybe they
were all but nevertheless it was an
enormous contrast between this remark
caterpillar your exam I know I thought
follow what Frank said I think it's just
a matter of time that you get some sort
of a critical mass and I think this and
they're teetering on the edge once you
get a middle class that has the where
what the on they're educated North that
they're going to hit some sort of point
where they probably could be very right
for a political Chitra large political
change and if you hold the people back
and they're uneducated and illiterate um
it's a lot harder I would think to
factor used there used to be faculty
exchanges and maybe student and graduate
student exchanges there's one person I
had as a lecturer had been to the US
twice as a faculty exchange had been to
a university in Missouri and another
place I forget she was quite
knowledgeable about the US but terrified
of saying anything in her in the
classroom in the lecture you know she
didn't really want to be that specific
about the political thing she was more
talking about history but there right
there I think that's where a lot of the
middle classes from and english-speaking
they've been to the US for a year or two
but I don't see the middle class at any
point in time considering the poorest of
the poor
I see the middle class you know working
for their voice for their property
rights you know they own nothing they
have a little bit of money and maybe
going forward and trying to get better
they still have this enormous poor
population that is facing what kind of
future it's bigger than our poor
population and look at what we're faced
with yeah but if the you know the extent
that you establish you middle class
people want rights property rights it's
very difficult to that itself it's you
beginning to establish any kind of
property rights it can help the Lola
farmers to to have some idea of their
property in both directions anyways
they're interesting one interesting
contrast is with Russia where you seem
to have a government that is becoming
increasingly ridic Radek increasingly
controlling whereas the Chinese
government is trying to hold out of
things but seems much more willing to
allow change that is outside its control
you know despite all he says you read
these stories about people being able to
do things and in Russia it seems to be
going off his direction they can almost
do anything they want to do and I guess
this goes back to dumb shopping when he
was when he took over from mal Satan
there was this tremendous hands off and
basically it seems that there still
a hands-off people can be as
intrapreneurial as they want to be and
the government helps with you know
economic policy and all that but the
government doesn't seem to try to
interfere much do you think the
government is helping with economic
policy in China when I was reading this
I felt that the government was basically
ignoring everything I didn't see them
involved in anything but we're going to
go forward and have power you know the
pollution the need for so many things
the the ignorance towards what they're
doing in their infrastructure the the
disease obviously the famine the future
what the government seems to be
underwriting in China our expenditures
for big things for means of production
absolutely and so the government seems
to be using its its foreign trade
credits and whatever to buy machine
tools and to buy instruments of
production so in a sense they're setting
a climate which incentivizes production
incentivizes manufacturing certainly the
average Chinese entrepreneur can't
afford big machine tools so the
government is contributing to the
economy in that sense that they're
underwriting those kinds of purchases in
directions in industries they feel are
important until it actually is overnight
and after than anybody that's right
that's right and so that's what they're
doin so to speak and then they let the
end that there seem to be letting the
individuals take over from there what I
thought was interesting about the book
was I felt that there was a slightly
alarmist quality this is happening this
is how this is happening and sitting
here kind of listening and talking about
what their life is like and their
governor
I was first struck by the idea that 20
or 30 years ago at least when I was
grabbed the idea was watch out because
if Russia comes over here we're gonna
have to live the way they live or
they're gonna take over and that's where
our life is gonna be like yet I can get
that I don't know if that was what he
was trying to say is watch out because
this is going to change our life or just
more this is what's going on over there
isn't it kind of interesting compared to
what we're doing and that that was
something I struggle with and reading it
trying to figure out what not what was
the point there's a point but there
wasn't a lot of analysis I thought and
so I just kind of curious about this
idea is this to say like watch out or is
it more just hey guess what they're
doing so what do you think is it to say
watch out both I think one is going to
be a district I mean watch out as far as
it's going to be a disruption our daily
and in our society and that we have to
once we if we happen to lose enough of
industries and segments of our economy
we're gonna have to adjust there's going
to be a real change but no one's gonna
like it basically number two you know
I'm not so worried about them coming in
here and telling us how to act and
behave politically and in political and
the political sense but I think if you
imagine you know the cruelty that all
the developing world is complaining
about how how the New Age imperialists
with their dollars are coming in and
you're not just just ravaging a
population just imagine a bigger you
know four times bigger than us just
running rampant all over the workers at
some point they're going to get to the
point where they're going to start
outsourcing stuff this competition is
going to raise somewhere else but
they're just going to treat everybody
else if they decide to treat everybody
else like like the peasants now at least
you know we we like to think that we
have a conscious and you know we can we
tend to police ourselves a lot better
you know overseas but I think the
Chinese and with their attitude right
now the government's been turning a
blind eye to what's going on with the
peasants and that's going to have a huge
impact on the rest of the world I think
and that's the scary part yeah so the
you know what the government is doing it
seems to be is basically similar to what
happens in the United States it's not
that they're oppressing the poor they're
ignoring them it's the people that are
it's the young imaginative types who are
flocking to the cities living in slums
and because they think it'll move their
lives which it does it's the people are
there at statistic in here that says the
average immigrant to Chinese big cities
sends home 545 dollars a year to rural
relatives god am i where do they get
five hundred forty five dollars to send
back that's a lot of money a lot of
hours of 40 cents yeah the it's partly
it isn't that they're oppressing 700
million peasants out there they're
ignoring them I don't know if it's very
difficult to know what else they can do
may I
you know to to raise up 700 million
people is not that easy and it's going
to take a lifetime of change to change
that Christopher
well I just wanted to to sort of mention
something the author alludes to which
sort of goes against his thesis that
China's is China's economy is getting
bigger and better all the time he says a
lot of young women factory who from the
countryside who go to the city quit
their factory jobs because they see that
there's no way that they can join the
middle class and they get they have no
option except to go home or to go into
work in nightclubs and many of them get
get sucked into prostitution that way if
he does mention that um although it goes
against the grain of his saying
everything else is saying that the
Chinese people are [ __ ] young the young
Chinese people are flocking to the
cities and some of them are lifting
themselves up in little class he's
saying a lot of these job is for these
young women in factories are dead end
jobs and so a lot of women quit these
jobs and go into the world of the of the
sports stadium sized nightclubs of the
cities and get sucked into prostitution
this tree does have a strong section
about women and how they're not happy
they go back get married if they go back
to the country and pick a different
option yeah well the noodle guy there
was a noodle guy in here and he wondered
if there was a place in America maybe
New York where he could make noodles so
my thought was all this success this
this economic growth these riches moving
to middle-class they still want to come
here
um why well I don't think that's it you
know he also refers to and you see
stories all the time about the
the people that come to the United
States gotten a PhD of this with that
and are going back to China there are
many in here so yeah I think that that
movement is also even stronger now this
was an awesome guy who went out and
became a noodle guy in the city and got
a little money and wondered if he could
make noodles maybe a New York person
chyann middle person u.s. might be
slightly Jeff are even peasant right
yeah yeah the peasant another
interesting factor you know on page
I think it's 93 he refers to the fact
that prices in Europe have fallen by 42
percent as a result of Chinese
manufacturer need the pressure from
Chinese competition and when he's
talking about Walmart he has that quote
in the Walmart thing Walmart is the best
thing that ever happened to poor people
we're never gonna get away from that
sure are we
I mean it's again when you forced prices
down I think I've said before that you
go to Walmart if you want to see what
poor people look like in the United
States go to Walmart yeah but the
Walmart if but if Walmart's a good
example of the local retail version of
China on the international economic
scene Walmart maybe the best thing that
happened to poor people in terms of what
their goods cost them but it's the worst
thing that's happened to poor people in
terms of the jobs that they have because
what Walmart does by not paying its
employees a higher wage which makes
impossible for them to set one of the
things that makes it possible for them
to sell things at a low price is that
they also know different benefits they
direct them to public services for the
benefits and I'm betting the u.s. I'm
sorry yeah this is in the US this is in
the US right so if his idea of Nirvana
if you will or an ideal situation for
helping poor people is the model of
Walmart I think there's some it it
creates and me a certain suspicion about
what he's talking about about how China
might be if China is good for the world
economy
well you know it was an article but I
think we've proven that an article about
an automobile company Toyota located a
plant in Canada just instead of going to
Georgia and he said the reason they did
it was because of health care in the
United States they would have to have
provided health care in Canada
yeah it just transfers the cost to
taxpayers I think you're going to see in
the United States the corporations are
going to really get behind the idea of
pushing the cost of taxpayers directly
to the taxpayers just to relieve the
burden on the corporations and it'll be
interesting to see whether you know
Democrats favor that on the idea well
you know anything good for corporations
is good for the United States but have
the taxpayers pay for it it's it's
exciting maybe necessary just because of
international competition but another
factor of Walmart you know if you want
to see disabled people working in a
store go to Walmart they hire an awful
lot of people who you can tell are not
the brightest metally who have physical
disabilities is not a good thing yes I
think giving people employment is a good
thing so it's not it's not a uniformly
black hat I'm not a black it's a black
hat is it not be in the gray flannel you
know if you favor if you think lower
prices are a bad thing I guess you got
to be against all of this kind of stuff
it depends on what you pay for lower
prices well and that's what that was
your point and the price did the person
for the delay Bigelow who pays
of their well-being their healthcare and
those kinds of things it's terrible
on that's the price that they gonna pay
for that and also if that's acceptable
that's fun I don't find it acceptable
and also he mentioned that Walmart is
wise 80% of its products in China so
that's so that's destroying good-paying
manufacturing jobs in America I think
you I think you have to look at Walmart
in several different ways their
employment picture their employment
policies etc are entirely Walmart
policies so they can strip benefits they
do all that for American workers that
has little or nothing to do with where
they get their materials that they sell
the fact that they go to China and they
buy most of their merchandise since
Walmart makes nothing they just sell
they buy their merchandise out of a
different economy the Chinese economy
that lowers price on one component has
nothing to do with their personnel
policies so it's Walmart is a
combination of lots of bad things and
one really good thing and the really
good thing is they appeal to all of us
as consumers in our consumer persona
every one of us has a consumer persona
Walmart is appealing and so they're
setting price standards which everyone
else in the world is now trying to meet
as he affectionately calls it the China
price and so that's the bad thing that's
what really is dangerous for us because
when you think of an American
manufacturing how in the world can he
meet the China price there is absolutely
no way so that's the danger it seems to
me going back to your question I think
we're all middle class there and we can
say
of ethical moral reasons we're not going
to buy it Walmart but for every person
who works at Walmart and it was
underpaid they're probably ten or a
hundred people who shop at Walmart who
can afford a refrigerator a TV that they
could not afford otherwise so I think
numerically you may have to say that
they do more good than evil
Carly well I wanted to change the
subject a little bit that's back back to
China China but I'm also looking at the
section about China and Europe and
European trade and how many European
countries have investments in Chinese
manufacturing companies and I thought
that was impressive
that'd be getting their sources are also
China but and Armed Forces exercises the
France Great Britain hold joint military
exercises with the Chinese Armed Forces
there was a section again I can't find
it but it seemed like France especially
is trying to circumvent the US with its
relations with China and in some ways
make certain the US isn't the only
dominant country in the world while I
have the floor I want to make a
different point about we the US has been
giving subsidy to payments to is Israel
to buy US military equipment but now
there's a news item that says well
Israel is selling it at a profit to
China so now we're concerned that you
know that Israel isn't just keeping and
using the military but if they're
selling it to China then we're concerned
but my point really is the Europe China
connection
I'm very brought that up I think that's
interesting
um and I do think countries have been
trying to play each other off and
China's definitely benefiting from that
all a lot
I think one of the best things that's
happened is that China has joined the
WTO because I do think that'll create
more of a you know extender dyes rules
and that they can't perhaps play people
off as ordinations off each other as
much as they they knew them copyrights
me um and I think he does get to that a
little bit I mean I think he says one
way to deal with the challenge of China
is to make sure that we're right with
the rest of the world I mean and I think
Huntington brings us up in his book on
the clash of civilizations as well you
know we need to be working in good you
know relations with with Europe with
India with the you know Russia as well
just to make sure that you know we in a
sense contain China just like we used to
contain the Soviet Union hmm I actually
wanted to shift it back away from China
for a second um something I thought that
that came up that was interesting on the
show we're talking about Walmart is that
I struggle with the concept of the US as
the great consumer and you know there's
obviously I guess you should segment the
population but there's a lot of excess
consumption and a lot of American
Society and I've always refreshment it's
saying okay well that excess consumption
actually my Hamiltonian perspective is
very positive globally because that
actually ultimately right raises you
know incomes of people let's order in
muster developed countries what happens
that's actually I kind of rationalize
this terrible excess consumption however
when you start reading this book the
excess consumption is subsidized by
Chinese peasants making 40 cents an hour
no one's actually winning except the
consumer and maybe a few capitalists in
China but seems like ultimately this
concept is Hamiltonian concept of sort
of globalization is good because it
raises incomes everywhere seems somewhat
based on his thesis flawed
I was wondering anyone else thought
about the utter
well I just have one sort of point which
which sort of relates to the condition
of Chinese peasant workers in the cities
in China I read in some news article or
maybe an economist that that Chinese
peasant workers some years ago objected
to say the United Nations or some or the
or some international wash'd
organization triumph trying to push for
better labor standards because and I
don't agree with this at all but because
not the workers were afraid where their
point of view was that if the Chinese
government if the Chinese factory owners
were forced to shape up they would they
would be they would lose their jobs and
have no livelihood at all now I think
it's terrible how how how the Chinese
factory owners and entrepreneurs treat
the peasant workers but I mean it's a
horrible injustice that spreads all over
the world's largest country and I think
that China may exhaust just natural
resources before it achieves its goals
of a tenfold economic growth in ten
years or whatever but I just remembered
reading somewhere that maybe workers not
in China biddle workers who were worried
that they would lose their jobs even
though the jobs were didn't give them
any event and if any benefits if
employers were forced to choose between
providing benefits and and just and just
cutting jobs
so that's just a small small point from
some magazine like The Economist just
something I read a few years ago when I
was reading this I wondered if 40 cents
an hour was what was reasonable pay in
China
go ahead boom - I guess point out the
consumerism is good for society but you
know I don't you know as a country the
US this whole time we've always sort of
had you know engineering sense the
equivalent of a heatsink
basically something that's dump
something to dump the excess energy or
whatever - we've always had somebody
something you're subsidizing is the
whole time I think that that's the thing
it's just now that we're becoming more
aware of it and we were looking back and
you know over the past 100 years you
know maybe we were even more subsidised
in the earlier part of the century than
we are at this point and so I don't I
guess I don't I would say that I don't
agree with the Hamilton concept that
consumerism is all that great
oh I don't imagine a world where
consumerism
you know abound and every and you find
stability without a some low-level MA
some in some developing country to be
sort of like your heat sink or your or
your way see or where your waste
by-product shows in the end it seems to
me the it's simply true I think the
China has to move more people out of the
poverty in the last 20 years then
practically the rest of the world
combined it's been an enormous changes
over there the other side of it is
simply that you know if you have 200
million people who have had lives
enormously improved you have 800 million
who have not but what are you going to
do about it I mean if you have 800
million people who are not making 40
cents an hour it's going to be true that
for a long time to come it's going to be
very difficult to raise wages in China
because you've got a lot of people who
will take jobs that 50 cents an hour if
they do have an aging
halation so this is their own account of
that swords poking them I read somewhere
that the generation that that the
Communist generation that fought the
civil war against China Chiang
kai-shek's Nationalist is dying in the
streets because the Chinese are untrue
you're not Chinese entrepreneurs are
have abandoned the sense of obligation
to take care of their elders all all
they want to do is get rich there's a
section in here about shame about some
of them going in front of tiny'mon
square and burning themselves and then
the shame that was brought upon
politically because obviously they were
mistreated or were more cast out or
couldn't find that didn't appreciate
what was going on the same problem is in
Japan for example you know how bad it is
I would imagine it varies enormous
across different families yeah but yeah
when you have the one-child policy it
means that one child is going to support
two elderly people well but what if that
one child refuses to support the two
elderly that make them exit even but
even if he's willing to do it it may be
difficult okay and consequences it
sounds like we're back to the time bomb
so you brought up Oh something like what
118 boys born for every hundred girls
right what does that mean in the long
run I mean there certainly there could
be trouble there I you know I think I
don't think it was here but other people
pointed to that that could make which I
to more of a militaristic or martial
Society just you're too many young angry
men looking for something to do and we
certainly knew that China and I'd say
fact yes
how the Chinese reacted when we to the
embassy where was that
he's a former Yugoslavia and you know
okay you know we we think was mistake
obviously but that you know we don't
know what could happen I mean if there's
so many young angry men out there what
kind of China could that lead to the
other example would be the holes in the
aircraft flew high down at that time
really brought us to to another world
war that's certainly another example how
tense it can become as this goes I mean
what happens to our living Stan
our standard of living as it as this
occurs and I've read that the Chinese
rulers are trying to stoke net and
encourage nail nationalism and national
pride among the Chinese common people
because they want to get Taiwan back oh
you animal
and they won they want the common people
to see the US as as a threat perhaps and
maybe as a distraction from economics
yeah it's not that it's been ever done
here well with that one big difference
here as you mentioned the analogy to
containment with Russia one big
difference is when we had during the
whole Cold War we were I can
economically isolated and we I come
Decker I guess I know whose fault it was
but there was almost no trade between
the United States and the communist bloc
they were both economically isolated and
one of the one of the advantages of the
present situation is the United States
and China are getting so economically
linked I mean if you trigger the United
States starting to war with China what
will do we buy the Walmart would close
down immediately and it's the same way
in the canton we don't what's true as
well yeah but would they sell - yeah
they started to war at Taiwan close down
all those factories dad it's a bunch I
mean we'll define problems but
nevertheless it seems to be a safer
situation from the standpoint of the two
governments making any decision
you disrupt the present system this is
that mean they're doing just a lot of
saber rattling across the straighten
that in Taiwan in the past couple of
weeks or however long it's been I mean
that seems to be getting tenser and
tenser as we yeah but when you when the
time comes to make a decision what title
do we have are they really going to just
stop exporting to the United States for
two or three years it's going to be a
different solution to your become Wow
that Europe is forget Europe the idea
the France take the idea of France
getting so desperate to exert their
influence in the world that they try to
make some kind of deal in China is
absurd
I think anybody else see Paul Krugman's
article yesterday about the floating of
the China letting the yuan float and
what the effects are going to be for the
possibility
and on it frizz stemming from the
balance of trade issues that they will
be buying fewer of our Treasuries and
with a smaller demand the prices will go
our interest rates will go up and dad
stopped imports of sweaters yes really a
couple of days ago we stopped that
wasn't stocked important yeah I had a
barnacle sweaters I thought we went to
the Greek and then there was noise about
oh well they may revalue the currency so
no no that has nothing to do it we were
we opened the doors to textiles and the
textile trade became so large so quickly
that we stopped importing sweaters
because if summertime it's 100 degrees
and we don't need a Ross but that's a
trade issue I don't see the train
stopping but I mean it might not be in
the Chinese interest anymore to finance
our debt and that's the best
really big like we lobby for this or why
did we almost make this demand on China
about that letting down we love the one
that it's flows the one your do you on
yeah yeah I I mean we
our government has been demanding that
because our manufacturers have been
saying we can't compete their their
products are priced so low because of
because they haven't let their currency
float relative to the rest of the world
and so it's a it's we're back to another
to it
sort if we make the their products more
expensive relative to our products it
gives our manufacturers of more of an
opportunity to compete that's less of
our debt somebody we have to sell our
debt to somebody we're going to have to
pay more to get people to buy our debt
so our interest rates will go on by the
way everyone's make sense I want to
switch to a floating rate mortgage
everyone's mortgage rates are not
swapping since when the midst of a
housing bubble we got our own little
time bomb ready to go off there yeah
another problem is that you know China
is sitting on so many hundred billions
of dollars of Treasury things so when
they let the currency float the bonds
they're presently holding are reduced in
value
and you don't want to do that either
yeah it's an interesting amazing a power
about but also to clarify what they're
doing some manage what it's moving yeah
right right so
and if you have a list and I don't know
we answered your phone
we loved your list so what else do you
have on there that you might be
interested in knowing from reading a
book I mean I guess one of the things
that interested me was how this
communist society seems to be proving
Marxism by turning everyone into the
proletariat which was basically working
through the okay so if you have lots of
jobs go to China people lose their
factory jobs they're desperate for jobs
they'll take any job that's available
that depresses wages and this sort of
this cycle that continues now somewhere
again this Chinese middle class is
developing which I'm not entirely sure
what's developing from I just thought
that was motley ironic that this
nominally communist country is actually
creating according to this guy class
proletariat in a number of different
nations including Aires lecture so what
do we think Bo about that observation
like I jumped to his conclusion
was solutions that earlier in the book
and I think you know the best impact it
was a book I guess is just awareness of
what's going on right now and you know
all the other remedies that hit the he
sets forth aren't going to happen
overnight but it's a good wake-up call I
think for all of us I mean we are we're
pretty fat nation at this point and yeah
I got I got admit you know I was I'm
first-generation and you know way back
in school my friends had already said
that I lost my Asian work ethic at some
point I'm a living example I guess you
know because I've made it through the
ranks and I'm pretty dumb fat and happy
right now
it was it it's hard to lazy I'm happy
because you're learning about China well
it's because I want to stay down fast no
but I think I think he makes a good
point as a nation we're not as fit as we
as we used to be we maybe fit in the
financial sector will be super smarter a
lot of people but you know we're not
producing as much I mean you go out and
try to find yourself a shirt that's made
in the u.s. I challenge you to do that
don't really be made in Malaysia I'm not
mistaken basically what I got from him
is that I mean we've lost manufacturing
and don't even try really to do that but
we just have to be innovative and more
entrepreneurial and basically our
workers so stop to be smarter we have
become all managers because the battle
for manufacturing and you know these
kind of services are it's lost
alright but they the point every that is
manufacturing and some of these low you
know they said nothing is low tech but
these sort of ground-pounding industry
creates a lot of stability in your
economy
I mean agriculture is certainly a big
the stable factor in our economy and if
we start losing and you
people have been saying for the last
almost 10 years now that oh you know
we're so smart now because the internet
you know we're just going to shift to
the service economy and we'll just work
smarter and you know you you were
talking about the patent there is no
such thing as an international patent
it's all WTO agreements or bilateral
agreements and you get a country like
China once it's you know it's political
cloud is up there already and once the
economic cloud gets up there we're not
going to have a say and whatsoever and
you know they can copy whatever the heck
they wanted to keep stealing from us and
so Daddy you know when you say you don't
have if you're buying stuff from another
country well you have a lot of clout I
mean you can just decide you want to put
you know the threat to put tariffs on
sweaters for example yeah the Chinese
apparently respond to that kind of
pressure if you're if you're their chief
customer you got close I mean for the
time being we have clout we have 16 a
significant amount of cloud still but
were you know you're not we're closing
that gap rapidly I think well as of 2005
the author says US manufacturing sector
is as large as the entire Chinese
economy I mean that doesn't end it
seemed to me to indicate that we've lost
all manufacturing you think a statement
is correct
I don't know correct factoring jonatha
construal output well they might be okay
there we go sir but again that's going
to the competitive right if we got be
more productive what do you know he's
productivity opprotunities nerve workers
but you're talking about we haven't lost
at the battle with the high ticket item
neither
I mean GE and then back to on others
guys still own the intellectual smarts
and how to create energy but you know
the problem I'll give an example and
it's a little more personalized but you
know a friend of mine went to China to
work for GE and he came back and he said
you know people are living like peasants
over there but he says it's amazing how
they're working GE you say they buy
their power turbines in three or four
phases the first phase is a complete
turbine multi-million dollar piece of
equipment the second phase is a complete
turbine taking apart or parts of a
turbine shipped over there phase three
is you know spare parts shipped over
there and additional training you know
and by phase four they're going to say
hey you know we figured it out original
things but the problem is companies like
GE and he's saying that the management
is saying that hey there's really
nothing we can do at this point we're
going to make a buck off or whatever we
can someone else oh yeah but we can't
stop them from from doing that and so
when we cross that threshold in which
our big-ticket items or big-ticket
manufacturing Boeing start to ship you
know I'm going to move on our smarts
over there we're going to start losing
the war and it's going to be drastic a
drastic change compared to what we're
seeing right now currently what did you
think overall oh well I was buried in a
lot of the detail I wanted me kind of
more of a policy or more of a where do
we really go from here kind of
conclusion that's why I was recently
focusing on the last chapter which
doesn't give us much it's another
anecdote kind of her another story
so in that sense I was kind of looking
for solutions or he doesn't have a
couple nice try not be any rate good
smarter yes so he said your point about
our education system and where we rank
in the world in terms of how we educate
our young people that's really a
significant it's a wake-up call it's a
wake up call about that but we're asleep
or their journey but we have heard that
before and I'm people like Robert
Samuelson have pointed out that you know
only four percent of the jobs or so need
algebra and you know or higher math
skills and that I mean as long as we
keep on a lot this book assumes that
we're being static and we're not static
our economy is changing you know and
people are coming up with new ideas I
mean Bill Gates and Microsoft wasn't
around
you know what over 20 years ago so
that's why I think in the end I I'm not
as scared as I think he wants me to be
well that's good that's good optimist
Barry what about you I actually am a
little bit I'd like to take I take your
point the youth over
I think I think the the difference is
that in the old days in America's growth
we invented things that we got to use in
this country the railroads aiwei's etc
all of a sudden Microsoft comes along
the internet comes along all those
things and reinvented them but everybody
gets to use them and everybody gets to
use them for no charge as you correctly
pointed out China has a very active
cloning business and they actually would
see it as a legitimate enterprise they
actually argue in the WTO that they're
not stealing anything that they're
entitled to it because they claim that
they're not going to be customers of
Microsoft anyway because nobody in China
can pay $600 for Windows so since
they're not going to be customers anyway
what's wrong with them making their own
and they've got lots of smart people out
of this 1.5 billion to do just exactly
that so it seems to me that if we bet on
technology and we bet on us maintaining
its edge in technology we're setting
ourselves up for clones for copying all
the technology at no cost to the copier
and therefore we do run the risk of
losing our edge in that regard well I
sort of think the gaps can be closed I
mean there's I don't know I'm worried I
worry about yeah yeah yeah yeah what
about you jack
well I'm worried also Gordon said that
China is where we were to
turn-of-the-century
last century was it okay well I will
postulate an aging of civilizations or
societies and I think we are past our
peak and we are sat and happy and I
think China hat is yet is on the left
side of the normal curve and we're on
the right side is if I don't say this
what is the slope
yes well there's as positive in ours is
that yeah what is curly you had
something wrong all right that's okay
had my turn oh you don't you can come in
any time this appointment I didn't see
anything about the Yangtze River Dam
which was is a major project and major
dislocation of people and whether it's
in effect doing what it was supposed to
be doing in terms of energy supply
electricity supply I don't see anything
here
it's been closed I mean it's been
filling up and and starting to produce
power for a couple of years now so there
should be some reference to secondly
China has maybe two or three other major
construction projects cross country one
is oil pipeline from Russia through what
to bed Banco Lee I don't know to Beijing
which will bring Russian oil through you
know through all of China and then a
third one is it another rail line
through all of from Europe into eastern
China and those are going to make major
differences within China itself and in
the countryside and to its
competitiveness I think with Europe with
Asia whatever so I was disappointed that
those I didn't see anything mentioned
about that their major major work forces
that go to those construction sites men
for years what I learned was there two
and five-year projects they don't go
home to visit their families as a part
of this they may not even be paid for a
lot of the time they're sleeping in kind
of giant tents with no real bedding as
just kind of caught sand long hours from
in the summer they were may work 1215
hours under those working conditions but
I was disappointed not to hear about
those
major construction projects - you think
they are a bad idea or a good idea well
it's certainly going to bring China more
into a competitive world which also not
lies the oil in urban areas yeah yeah I
don't necessarily think it's a bad idea
I think it's going to have a major
impact in China so it I think he focused
on the industrial parts of China and I
maybe that's what the title is trying to
Inc could very well be right left out
what you were looking for Paris what
about you what you think over me again I
thought it was less obviously histrionic
than a lot of books we've read so I mean
some books it was more subtle with thee
the world is going to end eventually is
the problem like it was much more subtle
with that but they do like as we're
going along it's like a now wait a
second hold on the banking systems a
disaster you know we're we might be
headed toward hyperinflation the
environments a disaster he mentioned one
sentence about how people are dying
younger one-sentence know that you know
china might not have such an aging
problem after all I mean frankly oh yeah
so I think there are a lot of problems
in this sort of march toward progress
that he didn't really go into and so but
sort of there was a cumulative effect
Nia when I first read the book I was
like oh dear God but that time I finish
I'm like you know he skipped over so
many of the roadblocks and yes I do see
something that's developing but it
ultimately may I don't think it we
should be as panicked as he suggests
I bet you Jennifer I thought it was very
interesting I just thought like a lot of
times I was reading a lot of lists it
was sort of like story after story
exists that nothing which was
interesting I mean I think I learned a
lot more about what's going on in China
um what next or what impact that has I
felt like wasn't like I said before it
wasn't dealt with as much so it's like
you've learned a little bit more of
what's next from our conversation okay
are you ready I thought it was a
worthwhile read yeah I kind of that you
kind of get overwhelmed with all these
gee-whiz figures that he throws out at
you and the fact that every one of us
there are five of them out there
somewhere I mean they're smarter last
night um so yeah I mean at first yeah
you're kind of concerned about it but
yeah he does kind of he doesn't address
uh I think he did talk about the three
gorges dam like maybe one or two
sentences he drew he talks about it but
he doesn't talk about the degradation
that's going on there we talked about
the human rights issues and those two
worker rights things and the other thing
that he doesn't talk about is the limit
to the natural resources an all day he
doesn't talk about that a lot and he
does talk about the fact that these big
cities that have come up overnight
they're under power curtailment because
they just don't have the power as a
result we we know that they're trying to
purchase único so I mean I guess it's a
concern but there are finite resources
that may may act will probably limit a
lot of a lot of that all right
very timely very time yes everyone but
you know I think I've already said
nothing Teddy over in the corner how'd
you feel um I thought it was really
interesting and I learned
a lot I'm I'm so impressed with the
scale of everything there and I should
have known more about it than I did um
the sheer scale of it is just astounding
but like you I sort of after a while the
building of this inevitability I thought
yeah wait a minute and I I think it may
just be you know good old-fashioned
American denial
we're so inventive and we've been able
to overcome where that we're all the
Marines I mean every one of us has that
sort of we can do it the bigger the
problem that you know the more
impossible the problem the more likely
we'll fix it so I'm sort of caught in
the middle of that but um but it was a
good Reeves good book to read this
conversations untrue Chris different
what about you
well um I think Teddy just said um I
mean I have pretty much the same
reactions as and the same and the same
sort of skepticism as she did I mean
being bombarded by all these figures and
he leaves so many problems out it looks
I mean his slant is exhausting after a
while that was my rack okay and then
lastly Gordon what did you think well I
think it's you know this idea that
things you can take a trend line and
extend it to the moon it seems to me
that seems to me basically as Tennessee
things are they've been doing well for
20 years therefore so clapping 100 years
maybe maybe not the I think he has one
sentence in there where he says is that
the Chinese have not yet shown that they
can be technologically innovative mm-hmm
like in Japan for example it's been said
for a long time that the Japanese
schools kind of stifle initiative and
innovation kind of thinking is a very
community oriented thing it'll be
interesting to see whether there's a lot
of Chinese scientists for example who
are have been innovative in Nobel Prizes
and things like that I think many of
them Chinese Americans but I think on
the whole that the I'm kind of I guess
like you say a Hamiltonian type that I
think I think all Americans should live
under a third world country for at least
some brief period and have some idea to
see what it's like to live on the dollar
a day and
it's hard to see that these kind of
changes are bad I mean yeah the stress
on resources and everything else is
going to be a problem for the world but
I can't see that we ought to encourage
people to live those kind of lives if
they can be changed in China has done an
enormous amount to change things
well the time I get there won't be a
third world country I'm certainly years
or so you'll have plenty it might take
me that long so Joyce what's your wins
what's you well I you know I found it a
scary buck when I was reading it may be
because of the dumb reason I'm thinking
how I want it to write down how many
people what does this equate to so but
I'm one of the young ones that has a
sense of fear and mostly I look at it on
a governmental side and a human right
side there it's very scary to me that
there's a country that is growing so
fast so rapidly in so many aspects with
so little concern or so little um
placement on people they can't get
anywhere if eventually their people are
without and I the thing that brought it
most to light was those employees that
used to work with the government who
were displaced and have nothing now and
are basically without and then I got to
the section about the Olympics and I
said you've got to be kidding me we're
going to China for the Olympics and all
this land that that they're going to
build the Olympics on we'll be
displacing people and I think that's the
exact opposite of what you know what we
should be doing but I'm not sure if I
would recommend it to anybody that
wasn't a scholar I would try and they
would all say why'd you send me this
block you know so overall with the
recommendation be to share the book or
to say it was just a read what do you
think share it or was it just a read
good selection I would I would say sure
carrot yeah
- you would recommend yeah okay cuz you
know we've had a few that we wanted to
throw against the wall you've said you
came here
well next month we to talk about about
August normally don't meet in August but
there's a group of us that are just such
avid readers and interested in our sense
of community we're reading running on
empty by Peter G Peterson who I also
think is a local author I'm not exactly
sure this was recommended by one of our
members so let's see how we do and then
in September we're reading the
International Monetary Fund from an
extension of our discussion on this is
the defense was supposed to be office I
think we've read the offense right risk
attempts there that's quite a few names
so there might be multiple more right
right and I'm not sure what the costed
at one is but so we meet in August for
that and September quiz it ignores um
22nd the 22nd the fourth Monday always
at 7:30 down here invite friends thanks
for coming and run almost yeah